[Music]
you amber
have you ever had like a weird random
thought
all the time
yeah
why did she ask me that
does she know i've been thinking about
making a reboot of samford and sun where
david allen greer plays fred sanford and
i play lamont
they should make pregnancy test
commercials where the test is negative
and then the couple high-fives
who was the first person to cuss
i bet it was jesus
[Music]
if we have yankee candles does that mean
there are also confederate candles
how much money did george jetson make
jane didn't work yet they lived in a
nice place and could afford two kids a
dog and a robot made
something doesn't add up
do robots have a dance called the human
i bet fred flintstone was a racist
i bet marvin the martian is black
[Music]
why aren't they talking
are we playing the silent game
it's time for wally to shine
i think tarik is hiding a secret life
i hope amber doesn't find out about my
secret life
is there a way to watch the bill cosby
show without having to look at bill
cosby
were the muppet babies orphans
[Music]
oh is it weird tarik and i haven't said
anything in a while i should say
something
well i guess we should continue on with
the show
you are right yes i win wally is the
king of silence bow before me
is a weirdo
oh crap did i say that out loud
[Music]
you